so far in motion as extension one
extension to students we've actually
like the vast majority measure maybe 90
percent of all the mission you've been
looking at has all been one-dimensional
as it along a straight line okay even
just thinking about the motion you've
been doing um very recently resisted
motion say motion through B you still
think about something traveling in a
straight line pretty much the only kind
of two-dimensional motion you've been
doing in any kind of detail is its
projectile motion
very good you've gone up up down and
then you've got you know across that
dimension and those two dimensions
that's that's the only kind of way to
describe okay there's an x and a y they
were changing okay today we're going to
move again into 2d motion two dimensions
only for the second time and in fact as
you'll see shortly we kind of add a
third dimension in as well but as you'll
do the questions you'll find it's mostly
sort of half dimensions you will say
well it's kind of like an extra
dimension which you have to worry about
but not in as much detail as you worry
about the other two dimensions okay so
circular motion in order to describe
circular motion there's one key idea
which is extra which is different which
is um I asked you to draw a circle okay
so you got a circle here you've got an
object that moves in a circular path
around a center let's call it P particle
there's your object yeah the order to
describe the motion of this object
you've got one of two choices you've
already got beautiful you've already got
the tools you have access to now so for
instance you could say ah how quickly is
this moving in terms of distance over
time that's speed right and you can see
it's going to be moving this distance
around the circumference of the circle
we'll talk about that in a second
however as you can imagine I'm going to
put some extra
there we go
when you met id bubble from the outside
when you imagined our brother was
imagined would you remember your line of
people and I use the word line very
loosely when you remember your line of
people moving around the idea the idea
was that you're all moving as a single
structure as a single body right and so
what you've got here is in a sense each
of the people along here moving at us
like a kind of velocity that should all
be the same okay now clearly it's not
that by experience you know it's not the
same speed at distance over time that's
being covered for instance this guy here
is covering no distance right there just
standing on the spot having a sweet time
laughing everyone else around them right
whereas this guy around here or girl
right is hiding all the way around is
really legging it to actually make it
work for everyone okay so in what way
can describe all of these as moving at
the same velocity and the answer is if
we place in and you can place it any way
you like if you place in some kind of
arbitrary fixed radius right we'll call
this our reference line we can measure
from there and angle measure this angle
yeah we get a cool feet up which can be
it literally can be measured from
anywhere but usually we fix a point to
say that they start measuring from here
we call this angle theta the angular
displacement the angular displacement
now displacement is a funny word to use
because this angle is it's all staying
on the same point right so it's
displacement maybe is not the best word
for it because you're always measuring
from here okay it's the same idea of
something changing which I can measure
right which I can physically measure I
can measure angle I can use projectile
that's what so I'm going to define theta
as angular displacement
and because we're thinking about motion
right we want to think about how this
changes over time what I think that has
changed over time so excuse me for
instance if I just differentiate with
respect to time just differentiate with
respect to time how has the angular
displacement changing as time changes
with time progresses right what would be
a natural name for this
we're from displacement if you
differentiate you should call that
velocity right so this is angular
velocity I'm gonna just leave a bit of a
gap and you shouldn't leave one to
angular velocity because you've got
something moving in a circle your whole
object is rotating so alternatively two
angular velocity it's also called
rotational velocity rotational velocity
okay now because this is such an
important idea right we have grown just
like when the other kinds of version
we've grown new ways of stating what
this is of actually using notation so we
already have a piece of notation which
means differentiate with respect to time
which we borrow from straight-line
motion for projectile motion
what's the particular kind of notation
we use for that a dot right so I can
call this t1 DT or I could call it theta
dot you'll see that as well but because
this is such an important idea and in
fact sometimes it's its own function
which you start with like we give it a
whole new special name we call it
frequently I make up okay
I draw my ma ma basically like a w but
more round and it comes around so this
is the way I thought
yes climbing like it's kind of like um
the way I picture it is it's kind of
like the bottom of an apple right so oh
yeah or if you've got actual muscles
which I do not yeah what's that mr.
balloon yeah so Omega is what we
describe as angular velocity naturally
because we've got displacement now we've
got philosophy you can also have
acceleration right
I would I would bother riding this
because this is the same thing angular
acceleration but how could I write this
as well just as a derivative here right
you could describe it as the second
derivative of displacement right I could
follow this convention here theta double
dot right how else could I keep going
what other ways could I say this you you
could say a remainder let's suppose in
theory how I've never seen it written
like that I'm not sure why I guess we're
trying to say in this scheme if you're
thinking of dots you go back to your
original things do you change maybe you
could uh you could write this as D Omega
DT right and because this is
acceleration just like we've had before
right you actually have a long string of
ways to say this if you recall this
result this guy here
you remember this right now we had a way
of proving we got from here to here
using general and a bit of integration a
couple of times right now I want you to
think I'll just leave it as your own
task for a minute how would you get from
just like we went from here to here how
you get from this to something similar
to this and what is it going to be
internal you just think about it
you just think complicated you do need
to be able to derive that it's not a
complicated result but if you can't
remember an option so there's a bunch of
different ways I can say is that just
like there's a bunch of ways that the
state ji-mun do you swim
I can sir
keep draw for me another circle draw for
me now listen
this is angular acceleration okay now I
said it's nice to be able to talk about
how angles are changing because it
doesn't matter how big your circle is
right you can describe the motion here
just in terms of this guy and this is
very very important and meaningful okay
however I guess some of you sort of
thinking to yourselves yeah but like if
I was this guy if I was this guy the
thing in my mind was not that oh yes
this is changing we're all changing at
the same amount the thing that was in my
mind was rotating at different amounts
and why did I have to be on the end when
my group was like to take people watch
that's ridiculous okay I got totally
ripped off so we distinguish between
angular displacement and your varsity
all that kind of thing with what I
mentioned before about how is your
distance changing your speed okay now to
distinguish between them I picture a
spot London right and what it's doing is
it's moving around moving that distance
because it's kind of moving in our line
it's kind of moving in a way we call it
linear velocity or linear displacement
and therefore the linear velocity
becomes along
and then of course you've got linear
acceleration as well so this guy this
guy is about distance over time right
which is why sometimes you'll hear this
talked about just this speed because
that's what distance over time is now
just that before that angular must is
sometimes called rotational was because
that's really what's happening for it
linear displacement linear velocity it
also has another name which comes along
from the fact of thinking about the
direction that this is headed in each
time okay now this conferences always
having anti-clockwise no big deal or
always heading clockwise the direction
does not change
however this this velocity is actually
facing in a different direction all the
time okay forest is at this particular
moment here it's facing off in that
direction right if you're running you're
running perpendicular to where the rest
of the people are right that make sense
as you move around though and that
direction changes it has to keep on
changing like so now because that
direction keeps on changing in the
direction of the tangent to where you
are at any given point in time in
addition to calling this linear velocity
this is also often called tension to
your faucet in the context of circular
motion these two things are the same
idea they're the same idea naturally you
don't have to be moving in a circle so
these two ideas are not always the same
but for our concerns and our purposes
that's what it looks like okay